welcome to episode 3 of the stronger by
science podcast we've gotten a lot of
great feedback on the first two episodes
so we are going to start releasing
episodes every single week from now on
every other episode is now going to be a
question-and-answer episode in which we
answer questions from listeners and this
is the first such Q&A episode if you'd
like to have your questions answered on
a future show check out the links in the
episode description to submit your
questions to us thank you for listening
and be on the lookout for new episodes
dropping every single Thursday
[Music]
what we're gonna do is go through some
questions that we have collected on
social media please continue to give us
questions that you'd like answered on
the show anything to add or should we
jump right into it in the show notes of
this episode I'll link the the social
media posts where we originally
solicited questions because there is
absolutely no way we're going to be able
to make it through all of the questions
that came in this time so we're gonna
kind of keep like a rolling list of
questions and try to get to everything
but yeah so we don't want to overlook
the people who ask these questions
initially but if you ask a question may
take us a while to get to it but we're
gonna try to keep everything kind of in
one spot to make sure we don't miss
anything all right question number one
what advice do we have for 40-plus year
olds working out you know people who are
not newbies but haven't made the
progress they would like should they
simplify and reduce workouts or just
continue doing whatever they can recover
from how do you address aging when it
comes to training and that's from Doug
yeah so that's a good question and and I
would say that the age of the person
we're talking about matters quite a bit
here so when someone says 40-plus
there's a big difference between like 42
and 72 and and typically I'm not gonna
worry too much about aging for men until
someone's like mid-50s or higher and for
women until their their postmenopausal
that kind of seems to be the age where
like like interesting things start
happening from like a senescence
perspective and when they're there is
like a reasonably steep decline of just
things physiologically yeah because I
should mention there's another question
by Matthew
you asked me what are the primary
reasons that older athletes aren't able
to perform and recover as effectively as
younger athletes so yeah yeah so for
someone who's like in their 40s and
let's say they've been training for
let's say like three or four years or
something like that I honestly wouldn't
take age into account all that much for
the most part you're you're just looking
for the same signs that any other
athlete is working for it is looking for
so you know are you feeling reasonably
fresh when you go to workout are you
kind of accumulating like wear and tear
type nagging discomforts and for some
people like so some people who are in
their 40s are in much better physical
shape than plenty of people in their 20s
and vice-versa so like if you compare
the populations of 40 something's to the
population of 20 something's like most
physiological things would kind of be in
the better direction for the 20 year
olds but like those two distributions
are gonna have a ton of overlap still so
I would pay more attention to just how
you're feeling as an individual versus
how you're feeling as someone in their
40s so I don't really think that without
any additional information I would make
like proactive changes to reduce volume
or reduce frequency or anything like
that if you're still making progress and
still feeling good those things could
absolutely stay where they are or even
go higher if like anybody else you're
feeling worn down and feeling like you
can't recover and you are doing a good
job of taking care of business outside
the gym then yeah like pull back but
that's because you as an individual
aren't recovery not you as a forty
three-year-old aren't recovery
yeah I feel like if you look at the
exercise science textbooks they kind of
oversimplify it and you kind of see that
the graphs they draw and it's like once
you hit like 35 or 40 it you know
there's this kind of steady decline but
in the real world that just doesn't seem
to be the case like I mean I know plenty
of natural bodybuilders who looked
better and better and bad
well into their mid-forties you know so
I'm kind of the the same opinion like
rather than take a defeatist approach
into it like well I turned 40 yesterday
so I should read completely reach him
you know restructure what I'm doing yeah
it's probably better to just be reactive
than than to try to get out ahead of it
yeah like Jim Thompson is in her 40s
still getting stronger
Marissa indos and her 40s still getting
stronger [ __ ] Dave Rick's is in his
50s still getting stronger or actually I
haven't seen much in the way of
competition out of him recently but I
know that I'm pretty sure the meet where
he hit his all-time biggest wall total
he was 53 at least up to this point so
like yeah to worry about yourself more
as an individual and how you're feeling
and responding to training and like I
said if you're you know if you're like
65 70 like time is really not your
friend at that point and okay now maybe
you are perhaps at an increased risk of
injury
you've probably accumulated a lot of
like wear and tear stuff if you've been
lifting your whole life now maybe it is
time to be a little more proactive to
decrease volume a little bit maybe
change training to add in a little bit
more explosive stuff there's there's
some research looking at older adults
and maintenance of type 2 muscle fibers
and like high-power
type training versus like high force
type training seems to be pretty good
for maintaining type 2 muscle fibers and
like functional capacity with age so
yeah you know when you're turning 60 70
like those might be some changes you
want to make 40 50 like I really
wouldn't worry about it too much yeah
you want to read the next question yeah
well so I I don't think we we answered
Matthews question very very well what
are the primary reasons older athletes
can't perform and recovers effectively
as younger athletes do you want to take
the first stab at that well I think the
kind of the most glaring thing that
happens as we age as we see big changes
in hormone
once you start getting to that 4050
range so it's usually around the time
that a lot of women hit menopause and so
there's obviously big hormonal changes
there and then with with men
testosterone that's usually around the
age where it starts to really taper off
so anytime you're talking about being
able able to train effectively and
recover and maintain body composition
the way it has been certainly changes in
sex hormones are going to be a big a big
influence on that yeah a couple other
things I would add that that I think are
overlooked a lot is one for for the
people we're talking to you're probably
more like the power lifter bodybuilder
type folks or Early's have goals related
to like building muscle maintaining
decent body cob getting stronger those
things probably aren't going to drop off
as fast as say like explosiveness would
and one point I always like to make is I
think one of the reasons people kind of
zero in on like ooh like mid-30s or like
ooh I just turned 40 like things are
really gonna start going downhill is
you're looking at professional athletes
and there's there's a big difference
between you and a professional athlete
especially you as someone with like
strength slash hypertrophy type goals so
one of the major reasons that
professional athletes really start
dropping off in their 30s and 40s is one
just like wear and tear from their sport
if you've been you know playing football
or playing real football soccer or if
you've been like playing basketball for
you know eight hours a day for 25 years
your body's just experienced way more
wear and tear than it would have if your
training was lifting weights for an hour
and a half four times a week so the the
kind of physical aging process is going
to affect them more just because they
put more wear and tear on their bodies
and then too those sports are going to
be really dependent on speed and
quickness and power output so so like
something like that would affect away
lifter as well but like so changes in
the nervous system occur such that you
can't recruit all of your muscle or all
of your motor units quite as quickly you
can still reach for recruitment it's
just not going to be quite as snappy so
like velocity is gonna drop off a little
bit power up it's gonna drop off a
little bit you get changes in connective
tissue so you lose some of the elastin
in your joints so they're not going to
be quite as good at like helping with
with plyometric type movements so like
none of those things are directly
effecting force output or are
necessarily going to be related to
whether you can still build or maintain
muscle mass so like it's going to be
really really obvious if you're a 40
year old basketball player and can't
jump quite as high and that could really
affect your game and how effective who
you are on the court but it's probably
not going to affect someone who's you
know just trying to add weight to their
bench max so so don't don't expect that
your physical decline relatively
speaking is going to be as severe as
that of a professional athlete just
because like the things that affect how
you can do in the gym aren't going to
drop off as fast as the things that will
determine whether someone's effective on
the basketball court or the soccer pitch
yeah I mean you and I have a lot of
mutual friends that they study you know
nitty gritty neuromuscular stuff be in a
lab and just in conversations with them
you know I don't I'm not an expert in
that particular area but they always
mention that when it comes to sport
performance the rate of force
development or the rate of torque
development is where a lot of the magic
is for a lot of sports and they also
mentioned that that's kind of one of the
hallmarks they see when they do studies
in older versus younger people is not
the total force that gets achieved but
the rate of force development so yeah I
mean that stuff starts to drop off a
little bit but that's not gonna stop you
from grinding out reps in the gym on a
traditional strength or hypertrophy
program yeah like your max will be fine
your bar speeds just gonna be a little
lower yeah I think I think you can
probably take
this next one Tomas Kazan asks according
to the conclusions of this church church
Ward VIN study and then links the study
we can put that in the show notes do you
believe that along from a long term
muscle protein synthesis standpoint it
would be equally beneficial for a person
to eat 5 grams of leucine plus 6 grams
of protein at breakfast as opposed to 30
grams of protein at breakfast if it's
simpler and easier to eat a small
breakfast instead of the addition
basically basically asking about like
leucine threshold type stuff are you
better off just reaching your leucine
threshold from eating like whole
proteins versus like some some smaller
amount of full proteins but then adding
and leucine to hit that leucine
threshold and hopefully having enough of
the other amino acids in your system
yeah I mean this is kind of from a long
line of studies that do similar
approaches right where they'll say like
what if we give a really tiny dose of
protein and we give it some branching
amino acids or some leucine or there's
all sorts of combinations and
permutations of this kind of research
paradigm and they generally look at some
post prandial period of you know a
couple hours after after the meal or you
know four hours or a handful of hours I
when I look at this kind of research I
think is interesting from a mechanistic
perspective of trying to figure out what
is really initiating protein synthesis
but in terms of real-world tangible
outcomes you have a really hard time
convincing me that a super small dose of
protein with just a bunch of leucine
with it it's gonna in the long term pan
out and be approximately equivalent to
having a decent amount of actual whole
protein intake obviously when we look at
protein intakes certainly if we want to
maximize muscle protein synthesis we're
gonna have to have a decent amount of
leucine in there but we also know you're
gonna have to have the rest of the
essential amino acids in reasonable
amounts
you know you need all of those building
blocks there and you were actually
telling me in the car in Kansas City
about a recent study that was suggesting
that even non essential amino acids
might have some kind of secondary role
when it comes to the kind of the body
composition effects of protein intake
weren't you telling me about that if I
did I don't remember yeah I feel like I
know there there's some interesting
research that I haven't looked in too
much to on glycine specifically most of
that research is done in like livestock
so like adding specific amino acids to
livestock feed and how that helps with
like overall development and especially
like adding more muscle which people
will then eat glycine seems to be pretty
clutch even though that's if memory
serves not an essential amino acid but
yeah I haven't looked into that too too
much I believe you were telling me there
was a study suggesting that a whack of
non-essential amino acids was that they
were linking it to maybe hyper fascia
like increased appetite is that ringing
a bell yeah yeah yeah yeah so you know I
understand why these studies are done I
think they're valuable in terms of
understanding kind of the pure basic
physiology of what initiates you know
acute muscle protein synthesis but for
most healthy people I think if you want
to take these literally as like
practical strategies to change your diet
based upon I think they're largely
attempts to solve non problems you know
I mean like so yeah what if instead of
having a delicious food for breakfast
that I very much enjoy I had an eleven
gram amino acid mixture you know and
that's really the kicker right there man
cuz like you know chickens delicious
steak is delicious eggs are delicious
I'm not personally a huge fan of
tofu but I know a lot of people find
that delicious but like leucine powders
[ __ ] disgusting it's not good and so
then then when you talk about like diet
at here and it's like what someone
actually gonna stick to like I don't
know man I'm not gonna want to take
leucine powder four times a day for the
rest of my life yeah I just I I don't
see again assuming you're of good health
and and there's no reason you can't eat
you know a whole protein source I just
can't see the benefit to saying I've
cheated the system and instead of having
a normal meal I've had six grams of whey
with five grams of leucine in it mm-hmm
and like I'm really stoked about that
the other thing is when we get out of
that you know short term window
following the feeding that little post
prandial window i still just struggle i
struggle just in terms of face validity
to believe that with these kind of
mixtures where there's really minimal
total protein and just a ton of leucine
or a ton of branched chain amino acids I
struggle to believe that in the long
term they're gonna have equivalent
effects on overall skeletal muscle
balance yeah I really struggle with that
just based on the the small quantities
of the other essential amino acids and
it's possible that down the road there
might be more research indicating that
the non-essential amino acids are still
fairly important in the diet yeah in the
the one place where I could potentially
see it being useful and and this is
still kind of a stretch is if someone's
like prepping for a bodybuilding show
and you know your your carbs are really
low your fats really low and now instead
of like 30 grams of amino acids from a
full protein source now you can get by
with like 5 grams of protein plus an
extra 5 grams of leucine or essential
amino acids and now you've freed up like
20 grams of amino acids essentially
which would be similar to like 20 grams
of carbs and like now maybe your carbs
can be slightly higher or you can eat a
few more grams of fat like
in a situation like that where where
everything is so tight potentially
there's some efficacy but like for a
normal diet I just don't see I just
don't see who it would be useful for
yeah that the place that my mind went
with it was more clinical so I was
thinking if you have some kind of like
severe GI condition in which you know
you're really struggling to get food in
or maybe even in like super clinical
situations where they're doing like tube
feeding and they're like how do we do
more with less here basically and again
like i IV stoked if research came out
and said actually we tested this over a
four-week period with resistance
training and muscle protein balance was
totally equivalent and instead of eating
130 grams of protein a day their total
energy from amino acids was down to a
quarter of that I'd say awesome but I
still probably wouldn't do it I think
it's cool that but more importantly I
just I'm very very skeptical that that
would really be the case when you talk
talk about not just short term changes
in synthesis only but looking at net
balance over weeks and weeks and weeks
with resistance training I just can't I
struggle to see how that total amount of
amino acid is actually gonna support
balance let alone net accretion yeah in
skeletal muscle I agree all right moving
on to the next one from ERG T what's
your take on long term spinal and joint
health when it comes to lifting
frequently for years on end
especially with frequent heavy movements
that load the spine I worry that when
I'm 50 I'll just be crippled I don't
even move particularly heavy weights but
still a concern dot-dot-dot this is
super relevant to what we were talking
about at dinner the other night what was
that if for a man who forgets no facts
you forget every aspect of your know if
if someone like asks a question where
the
the answer to the question is a specific
fact I'll know it but like if it's a
vague thing like this reminds me of what
we talked about at dinner the other
night when we talked about 40 different
things I'm not gonna filter that down to
like the one conversation topic we were
talking about how a lot of people that
lift in terms of imaging they're likely
to have some kind of abnormality in area
eventually but that in many cases it
might not actually be symptomatic or
require any kind of invasive treatment
yeah but what we talked a little bit
about spine health in lifting and and
the simultaneously awesome but really
sobering Ronnie Coleman documentary
mm-hmm Ronnie Coleman has a special
place in my heart because when I first
got into bodybuilding it was like just
on the tail end of his career mm-hm and
like he was just so special but anyway
you want to take this one yeah yeah so
the the only the only study that I've
seen that's looked at rates of joint
degeneration in lifters versus non
lifters kind of chronically was a study
by Fitzgerald and colleagues back in
1980 and what they did is they recruited
folks who were were pretty high level
power lifters and weight lifters and
then they recruited age-matched controls
and I don't think they looked at the
spine in that study but they looked at I
believe wrist shoulder hip knee and
elbow and just looked at like cartilage
thickness and what proportion of each
sample had signs of like risks of
osteoarthritis or like actual
osteoarthritis and in that study they
found that that rates of joint
degeneration were very similar for the
lifters versus the the non-training
controls and I want to say the people in
that study were like in their 40s and
had at least like 10 15 years of lifting
experience so so pretty good sample for
that but the the catch for that study is
it doesn't account for survivorship bias
so it very well could have been
those were the folks who had stuck with
lifting that long because their joints
were just quite robust and could take it
and maybe 80% of the people would have
never made it into this study in the
first place because their joints all
broke down before they would have
qualified so so that's that's like a
possible interpretation issue with that
study so in terms of like frequent
loading I kind of think that and I have
no research to back me up here but I
kind of think like some people are fine
and some people are just kind of screwed
TBH like I think like yeah there are
some folks who just go hard and do a
bunch of dumb [ __ ] for like decades on
end and are fine and there are some
folks like you look at them lifts
everything looks fine their training
program is generally sane but like
they're constantly hurt like something
is always wrong and so like this
probably isn't a very helpful answer but
for some folks I think you just kind of
have to take things easy and play it
safe or you're you're probably just
going to run into issues and some folks
are just much more robust and can can
get away with a lot there is some
research looking at like different
genetic markers and injury risk and
athletes that basically comes to that
same conclusion that some folks just
have like different genetic variants
that make them much more robust to
injury and some folks like they're if
they're training reasonably hard for a
reasonably long period of time they have
a much much higher injury risk so I
think like for anyone you can do like
the general smart things make sure your
technique is good if you have any joint
issues be pretty conservative with them
make sure you keep a good training log
so you see like okay my shoulder is
bothering me
if I look back over my training for the
past couple of months here's how it's
looked okay make a note of that shoulder
gets better start training again start
taking it easy for a while shoulders
fine start ramping up volume or
intensity okay now I have shoulder
issues again look back oh wait my
shoulders started bothering me here when
I was doing about the same amount of
volume as what I was doing previously
okay maybe I just don't go quite this
high anymore
so so yeah just letting your body be
your guide making sure you're keeping
good records whoo so you know where
those thresholds are for yourself and
for some people like I said you may be
able to get away with a lot and for some
people it may be like much much lower
threshold yeah I think something that is
worth mentioning is first of all you
mentioned variation between between
people there can be so much variability
in terms of how certain joints are
physically structured those for sure
joint geometry in general and I think
that can dictate a lot of what you can
get away with and so like one of the
very glaring examples of that is is the
the shape of the I think the acromion
process yeah some people are just
screwed and it's it's just shaped like a
big giant hook and it's like you know
what like overhead pressing is gonna
give you problems man like if you're not
extremely cautious about it another one
sure would be a shame if that
supraspinatus tendon came anywhere close
to me exactly yeah same thing with with
the hip joint a lot of people it's like
dude like your hips the way that they
are built if you're not careful you're
gonna run into trouble you know yeah so
I I think that's a big thing that comes
into it that you know you might be the
kind of person that yeah I can load my
spine all day and not have any trouble
with it but overhead pressing especially
with higher volumes kills my shoulder
like you got to play it by ear and kind
of figure out for you what are the
things that that really seem to get you
in trouble yeah I know for me personally
it's not necessarily a volume thing but
a load thing like if I do any light like
really light bench-pressing even if I'm
not doing high reps with it
if it's not heavy I can get away with
kind of sloppy technique and when my
technique gets sloppy my biceps tendon
running through my shoulder it's just
brutal like so much pain so like the
longer you're in a lifting career you
you kind of figure out what your what is
triggering pain for you and you adapt to
it so like I started lifting when I was
12 and did a lot of really stupid things
and had a lot of pain and you'd think
that over time it's like well it's just
paint on top of paint on top of pain but
what I found with the exception of like
major injuries is you kind of learn how
to train around just the crap you were
born with you know so like the the
little aches and pains are way way
better than they used to be yeah you
know so so so like you said there there
are some like joints and some exercises
where just shits gonna be problematic
one thing that I see a lot that gets a
lot of people into trouble is they
either like follow popular training
programs as written and if there's a
lift that doesn't particularly work for
them they're hesitant to sub it out so
like for example there's people with an
acromion that just doesn't really allow
for high volume overhead work within
really after like 5 3 1 got popular like
overhead pressing got really popular and
kind of like general strength training
when when it had been out of favor for a
while and for a lot of people like over
for most people overhead press is
perfectly fine for a subset of people
like overhead press is is probably gonna
cause issues but like they follow the
program as written and wind up with
problems when if they would have subbed
out overhead press for something like
high incline press which which would
have had similar effects training wise
but may have been a little bit
friendlier to their shoulders they would
have been fine and also like their there
are a lot of so you mentioned hips
a lot of people who have issues
squatting to depth where they could get
the vast majority of benefits out of the
squat if they just cut it a little bit
higher people on the internet would make
fun of them though true yeah but but
that's that's something that that Stu
McGill has talked about a lot like a
fair amount of folks of like Irish and
Scottish descent their their hip flexion
range of motion is just limited compared
to the majority of other people and so
like you you can get to a little bit
greater than 90 degrees of hip flexion
but go much further than that you're
either going to be like at end range of
motion for hip ligaments which is not
good or you're gonna have to go into
some spinal flexion to hit depth which
also isn't good
and so like folks like that you know
squat like two or three inches above
parallel you'll be fine like probably
lower injury risk you'll still be able
to get the vast majority of the same
benefits you would have gotten from the
squat anyways but yeah like everyone
says like Oh got a squat ass to grass
and there are some people who just
shouldn't squat ass to grass so like
Eric said like make sure make sure
you're tailoring your training programs
to exercises that work well for you and
make sure you're tailoring range of
ranges of motion for the exercises you
do do two ranges a motion that you can
handle one very piece of practical
advice I would give is if you train at a
gym where there are several like older
lifters who are still getting after it
just go up to them and ask them like how
was your training different now from how
it was when you were younger and if
you're someone who's who's kind of
approaching training pretty
conservatively like you know how can I
minimize my risk versus necessarily how
can I maximize all of the progress I
could possibly make just listen to what
those guys say and try implementing some
of it like they they have found ways
that for them have allowed them to train
hard for 50 years and they found that
maybe some of the stuff that they were
doing 10 years into the process started
causing problems thirty years into the
process they would probably have
several nuggets that you could could
learn from and apply to your own
training if you want to approach things
a little bit more conservatively yeah
now that original question mentioned the
spine we also got a question from James
saying would love recommendations for
lifters with spinal loading issues the
other night we were talking about the
fact that if you were to just take a
random sample of people that have been
doing the power lifts you know heavy
squats heavy dads for a while even even
if you just took the general public I
think that you you're going with imaging
to find some degree of abnormality
somewhere along the spine you would
imagine right how to expect it be a
little bit higher prevalence in lifters
so one thing that we chatted about at
dinner the other night was the fact that
just because there's an imaging
abnormality doesn't necessarily mean
like okay time to cut me open you know
and a lot of times I mean obviously you
have back pain you go to a doctor you
listen to your doctor but but I think
sometimes we worry a lot about because
it looks bad right oh there's 600 pounds
on your back
maybe that's hard on your back right
like that's a pretty intuitive kind of
thought to have but I think you also
have to consider like what if I did no
spinal loading at all and like the
general population does tend to have a
great deal of back pain like back pain
is extremely prevalent mm-hmm and I
think I think there's got to be a sweet
spot in the middle right where there's
like some responsible level of loading
that when done properly and safely is
not just harmless but probably actually
to some extent beneficial for spine
health and then obviously if you go too
far and you're getting a little bit
ahead of yourself and going crazy with
it then you're probably likely
contributing you're some painte down the
line now when it comes to people with
pre-existing loading issues maybe
kyphosis scoliosis do you have any
practical tips for for that kind of
situation yeah so I am someone who has
spinal loading issues I also still
to be a powerlifter so I've had to
negotiate this for myself for for the
better part of a decade now and and not
just the spine but if you look and see
like what what kind of are the
mechanisms of injury for most joints
acute injuries are the most common when
a joint is loaded to a substantially
greater degree than the tissues are are
like accustomed to and have adapted to
and chronic injuries tend to take place
when a tissue is exposed to relatively
high loads with with insufficient like
time or ability to fully recover and
typically associated with some sort of
technique issue as well such that the
tissues each time they're exposed are
being stressed more than they probably
should be so I think one practical thing
a lot of people can do if they have
spinal issues is one to go to a physical
therapist like that's that's their job
like to help you like fix injuries or
reduce injury risk too if you're gonna
be stubborn and not go to a physical
therapist shame on you still go to a
physical therapist but if you if you are
going to be very stubborn and do it
yourself I think a practical step
someone can take is to make sure that
your spine is is robust to different
types of loading so one thing that I've
noticed when talking to a lot of lifters
who have back issues a lot of times like
the original problem didn't occur at the
gym so like you know they were squatting
and dead lifting in the gym and
everything was fine and then they go
down to like pick something up off the
floor and like a weird position and
something strains or they're like
grabbing something off a shelf that's
like where the center of mass of
whatever they're grabbing is
considerably in front of their body and
that does something weird and now their
back hurts or like they're trying to
grab something while they're also like
twisted a little bit and as soon as they
pick it up like they feel a pop now
everything hurts so
we we tend to in the gym really like
only load our spines like in the
sagittal plane like flexion extension
that's about it and really we try to
minimize flexion and extension as well
so like we're we're getting our spinal
extensors really strong for an isometric
contraction in a fairly neutral position
and that's like literally all we do and
so like yeah then you're going for a max
deadlift you get pulled into a little
spinal flexion now you're putting great
loads on your spine any position where
they're not used to dealing with load
and and you wind up with a problem so I
think something that people can do is
like starting with very very
conservative loads like just just take
your spine through a range of motion
like through a full range of motion so
you want to do like lateral flexion you
want to do some twisting you want to you
know hinge down actually let your spine
go into spinal flexion and just hang out
in that position like if you're
stretching your hamstrings or something
go like side to side like add a little
bit of lateral flexion along with the
spinal flexion and just like make sure
your spine can move through the entire
range of motion it's supposed to be able
to move through and you're doing these
unloaded yeah yeah yeah absolutely start
unloaded and then you know to once once
you're sure that like you can go through
those ranges of motion unloaded then
just add like some very light loading
into it so there's an exercise called
Jefferson curls which is essentially
just like rdls but with maximal spinal
flexion try doing some of those like
with a very very like light weight like
like I'm a seven hundred pound deadlift
er and I never do Jefferson curls with
more than 135 and typically with like a
30 40 pound kettlebell so we're talking
starting with like 1015 pounds like
something very very light you know do
some side bends and and don't hold one
weight in each hand that's dumb and it
doesn't do anything but like do side
bends one side at a time holding a
weight just in one hand
and like actually trying to see how much
like lateral flexion you can get each
rep so your your training those muscles
through a full range of motion
occasionally doing like single arm
deadlifts so you're gonna be getting a
little spinal flexion and a little
lateral flexion as well and yeah like
just try some things like that start
with very very very conservative loading
and just make sure that your spine is
capable of moving through those ranges
of motion and being exposed to some like
very conservative loading through those
ranges of motion that that's that will
probably help your back in the gym and I
I definitely think it's gonna help with
reducing injury risk in day to day life
when you're just putting your back into
position it's unaccustomed to because
there will be fewer positions that it's
not accustomed to and a while back you
got me on to those like breathing squats
where you kind of sit in the hole and
take deep breaths what do you think that
would have applications for I don't know
I just think they're great so I think
that uh so so with breathing Paulo
squats one you're gonna do them really
light and as you hang out down in the
hole like generally some people go or
most people go into a little bit of
spinal flexion when they're down there
so I think one that's going to expose
you to some loaded spinal flexion but
with a very very light and manageable
load and then two I think that a lot of
people are are really dependent on
intra-abdominal pressure to support
their spine when they're lifting and so
just by doing those breathing pause
squats and like fully exhaling again
when you're under very very conservative
loads that just helps like your
intrinsic spinal muscles figure out how
to brace when they're not being given
the assist of intra-abdominal pressure
so that that's also something I've done
that like I'm not gonna pretend like I
know mechanistically why it helps but
it's definitely helped my back a lot and
it's it's helped a lot of people who
I've recommended do it so
yeah possibly worth a shot as well again
starting with very very very light
weights yeah I love those those helped
me out a lot because I was having some
pretty serious back pain at a time but
you told me to go white and I didn't
take that as literally as I said I was
like I know what light is and I yeah I
didn't I was a little bit ambitious with
my weight selection but I learned
quickly now another thing to keep in
mind you know if you have a clinical
condition relating to your spine
obviously you need to have somebody in
your corner that can help guide you
through it a good physical therapist a
good orthopedic specialist but it's also
important to realize that it's not like
you have one spine abnormality and it's
like a death sentence like well I guess
I'll never do what I love again you know
I feel like most lifters have if you
talk to somebody that's like 45 and
they're good at powerlifting they've
been told at least once in their career
well you're definitely never gonna squat
a deadlift again you know what I mean
and you look at somebody like Lamar Gant
like arguably the best dead lifter of
all time I don't even think it's
arguable yeah I mean he's a legend and I
mean he was dead lifting with like
severe scoliosis it was like a 30%
curvature now does that mean everyone
with scoliosis it's like yeah just go
for it a hundred percent like no you be
smart like obviously any clinical
condition there's gonna be all sorts of
considerations that are specific to your
case but you know I coach a Special
Olympics powerlifting team we've got a
lifter with pretty severe scoliosis and
kyphosis he does a fantastic job and is
a hell of a dead lifter not long ago a
couple years ago he was pulling well
into the mid 500s at a body weight of
like 220 geez
yeah he was he was getting after it
that's legit yeah yeah the thing that's
awesome like Special Olympics is cool
because like you go in there and like
there's a guy on our team that can bench
weigh more than me there have been guys
that squat more than me and
guys that deadlift way more than me like
they're freaking good athletes man
mm-hmm
we've got a guy who man it was like two
years ago he threw on a slingshot and
just like loaded the bar with like three
thirty five and just pumped out like a
set of twelve like it was just crazy
like so yeah it's a good time if you've
never been to a Special Olympics meet go
to one they're a lot of fun all right
now on the topic of the spine we talked
about those breathing's breathing squats
and kind of how they help you get a
little bit less reliant on core bracing
if you lean a little too heavily on that
and that intra-abdominal pressure now we
did get a question about belts so
questions from Alex for an advanced
lifter is beltless training useless I
can't find a way to justify it take two
advanced lifters one who trains with the
belt all the time the other who does a
few blocks of beltless training per year
who will be stronger whoever picked
better parents and has better genes no
so serious answer I think that there's I
think that there's inherent value in
being able to lift heavy without a belt
I'm not entirely sure what it is but
like so for a long time I only trained
with a belt and I could squat like seven
plus with a belt and anything over 405
beltless felt like very very iffy and
like I can't prove that that's a bad
thing but it just it felt it felt wrong
to me and and I kind of think that again
there's two questions like one what's
going to get you the best results in the
gym and then two what may set you up for
unnecessary risk in the rest of your
life and like I said a lot of the people
I know who have like back problems they
train around for lifting they actually
initially injured their back doing some
other random [ __ ] and like so I think if
if you are ever going to be exposed to
spinal loading in life and you're not
planning on
weighs carrying your gym bag everywhere
to make sure you have a belt handy like
every time you help someone move or just
like pick up something random it's
probably not a terrible idea to be able
to also squat deadlift do things and in
the gym reasonably heavy without a belt
just to make sure you're ready for you
know the other 22 hours of your day
every day and if you're a power lifter
you're like everybody's like default
like moving buddy correct right and if
you own a pickup truck Jesus like you
are done yeah you'll spend your entire
summer moving people yeah so so what I
would say is I'm not aware of any either
direct or indirect evidence that would
suggest that just for improving squad or
deadlift one rep max girl you'll be
better off doing dedicated training
without a belt and I think there is
indirect evidence suggesting you may be
better off just training with a belt all
the time
you can obviously lift more weight
there's some like older research by
Robbins and colleagues I believe
indicating that actual muscle activation
for your quads and hamstrings may be
greater when you lift with a belt
even if load is equated which which i
think is pretty cool
maybe it's just like your spine
realizing like oh I'm a little safer
like we can pass these like motor
impulses through to the other muscles a
little more efficiently like I don't
know if that's the case that's just kind
of the story I tell myself to explain
those results but yeah like I think it's
I think it's entirely possible that just
purely from a training perspective
you're better always lifting with a belt
but I do think there is like inherent
value and still being able to lift
pretty heavy without one just possibly
to reduce injury risk in day to day life
yeah I mean like you were saying back
when I was like squatting a lot it was
like always with a belt and I felt like
my spine was completely ill-prepared to
deal with any kind of perturbation you
know what I mean so like like you were
saying helping somebody move something
I'd be like unless like everything's
perfect
spine is like not gonna be able to
accommodate this because it's so used to
working in one plane with a belt in a
very specific set of circumstances so
even like just miss grooving a squat
like getting a little bit out of my
wheelhouse in terms of spinal loading I
felt super vulnerable mm-hmm back when I
disliked it only training with the belt
you know ya know well I mean it's like
dude I've heard so many stories of
people who are like really serious
lifters and then they just get invited
to play basketball with friends for the
first time in like five years or like
just get out and play a pickup game of
soccer and then like they strain a
muscle or they like sprain a ligament or
something like that and it's like well I
guess I should have seen this coming
like I haven't played the sport for a
long time like all I ever do is squat
and deadlift and it's like people look
at that and they're like yep should have
seen it coming like these tissues that I
injured were ill-prepared for the
challenge I place them on but then it's
like you know you pick something up from
a weird angle and day-to-day life and
hurt your spine it's like who could have
seen this coming like i deadlift 600
pounds like I felt that my spine would
be ready and it's like well yeah like
that quad strain you got playing
basketball like you also squat 500
pounds but like you never do plyo so
that's like a new challenge being placed
on those tissues and it's like you never
load your spine in that range of motion
and you only load it when you have a
belt to help with intra-abdominal
pressure so who cares what you dead lift
your spine was also very Oprah paired
for that thing that you were doing in
day to day life so yeah like I said
before just like do some stuff to make
sure that your spine is is robust and
can do things other than perform two
lifts yeah and that's actually a good
segue so you mentioned like things in
day to day life you know there's some
kind of inherent health benefits when it
comes to getting stronger now we had a
question from Shane at what point does
someone hit the point of totally
diminished returns when it comes to the
health benefits of getting stronger so
like for example increasing a squat from
400 to 450 pounds are you any better off
when it comes to your health or just
kind of preventing injury in day-to-day
life like where do you assess that that
point where if there is a point where
you're talking about diminished returns
there do you want to take the first
crack at this one I feel like I've been
talking a lot yeah yeah we did get a lot
of your the training guru and I pretend
to know about nutrition so this has been
a Greg heavy episode but I don't think
anyone's gonna complain about that I
would say it doesn't take that that much
to be a healthy person so when I think
about you know right now I'm a
world-class elite professional
bodybuilder right which basically means
I spend several hours a week curling and
doing tricep extensions when I'm no
longer a competitive bodybuilder there's
no way man there's no way I'm gonna
waste another second of my life doing a
tricep extension so like I already kind
of have my plan of how I'm gonna
exercise after competition days are
behind me and it's gonna be about
loading the spine I'm gonna you know
keep in squats and deadlifts using very
manageable loads the goal is not going
to be to break any incredible 1 1 rep
max markers it's just is my spine
prepared to age gracefully and
accommodate my lifestyle so you know I
see my training going more towards am I
getting in there getting my heart rate
up cranking through some calories
loading the spine approximating things
that are gonna be useful you know so I'd
probably do a lot of single leg lower
body exercises to make sure I still have
balance and stability train my
explosiveness because I was as we talked
about rate of force development takes a
hit as we age and I'll probably do a lot
more the c-word as much as I hate to
admit it I'll probably have to get some
cardio in hopefully by that time I live
near a body of water and I can just
tattle board all day because that's
pretty fun but my take in it is I mean
we're we're
moving to Raleigh so if if global
warming keeps going the way it's going
like by the time we're 70 that's gonna
be like a seaside resort town exactly
yeah it's gonna be like Panama City
Beach in Raleigh it's gonna be beautiful
so my my impression in terms of like if
you're training for life I would say
trying to maintain body composition that
that correlates well with positive
health outcomes getting your heart rate
up a few times a week and then making
sure that that you have balanced
explosiveness and a robust enough spine
to basically handle activities of daily
living so I think you can live a
tremendously healthy lifestyle without
having a you know 400 plus pounds squat
that's my interpretation ya know I very
much agree I think that I think that you
probably want to build some level of
strength reserve when you're young cuz
like we said forties fifties not all
that exciting from an aging perspective
maybe a little more exciting for women
than men because of menopause but 60s
70s especially the 80s like things
really really start going downhill and
so I think like you probably do want to
be quite a bit stronger than you
actually need to be before that occurs
and this question mentioned a 400-pound
squat like dude that's plenty when you
talk about people not being strong
enough for activities of daily living
it's like they struggle to walk up
stairs while also carrying groceries
right so you know that's like can you do
a low step up carrying 20 pounds in each
hand if you can squat 400 you're plenty
strong enough for that or people having
issues standing up out of a chair or
like standing up off the toilet yeah so
like being stronger than you need to be
is good but we're talking like if you
squat and deadlift one
half times your body weight you have a
tremendous strength reserve yeah like
you're gonna be god-awful at
powerlifting like like that's not gonna
turn heads in the gym but like you have
way more strength than you need to for
day-to-day life at that point and so I
think like as long as you're there or
like slightly beyond that you're
probably is as strong as you really need
to be for health benefits and a lot of
the health benefits from resistance
training are in the actual strength you
build having that functional reserve as
cinesín starts kicking in but a lot of
the benefits are just from resistance
training itself
so like obviously building muscle and
getting stronger is good but like there
are additional benefits just from the
actual act of resistance training that
that are independent of how strong you
are so I think like most of the health
benefits you'll get from lifting are
just from from lifting and then yeah
like I think decent benchmarks squat and
deadlift one and a half times body
weight like you're probably fine yeah
speaking of which you see that video of
Arnold getting a kicked at that event
yeah I think he was in South Africa yeah
so if you haven't seen in the videos
everywhere he's just kind of standing in
this crowd I think was that one of the
Arnold sports festivals maybe yeah and
somebody just runs in out of nowhere and
like jumps and kicks him and the oak man
he just like stood there I was like what
I think he's completely unfazed totally
fine yeah he posts on Twitter later like
hey guys I'm fine I thought I just got
jostled in the crowd everything's good
it's like he's white like 71-72 dude
yeah how many seventy two year olds
could could just absorb being blindsided
by a full speed flying dropkick to like
the shoulder blade yeah incredible like
at that age honestly for a decent amount
of the population that's a death
sentence tripping is a medical emergency
yeah like he got freaking drop kicked
blindsided and just like barely moved
yes so so you probably need a slightly
larger strength reserve to uh to deal
with the the flying dropkicks we all
risk in day-to-day life but yes I
actually want to revise my answer to the
last question just to be safe for
healthy aging be the best bodybuilder in
the world for like a decade yes like
knock out five or six mr. Olympia's and
like keep it training really really hard
for the next 40 years
yeah and that's probably about what you
need okay so we got a couple other
questions we talked a lot about training
now let's talk a little bit about the
academic side of things so we got a
question from Brian what would happen if
Terry towel started devoting his time to
studying and publishing an exercise
science assuming he has all the
resources and stuff that he needs what
kind of progress would the field make so
so just for background Terry tao is a
fields medal winning mathematician he
was I think he was a full professor at
UCLA in his like early 20s like 23 or so
and I believe he's somewhere in
Australia now but if memory serves like
one of the reasons he's like famous is I
think he has the highest like verified
IQ ever which like at that point I don't
really trust it because like this
typical stanford-binet scale kind of
starts getting very iffy once you get
past like three or four standard
deviations but whatever like a lot of
people believe that Terry towel like IQ
wise is the smartest person ever
so just for listeners who don't know who
Terry Tao is that's who Terry towel if
you haven't been keeping up with the
field of mathematics yeah shame on you I
knew all this going into it so what what
do you think I don't know I mean there
there are some really smart people work
in an exercise science
I think the
when it comes to exercise science
obviously you need to have a decent
understanding of the theory and and the
knowledge that's already present but I
think honestly what exercise science
needs is people to actually pound the
pavement a little bit like it's an
applied field in which we need human
data we need probably some some changes
in how we do things when it comes to
collecting that data namely I think we
would really benefit from having larger
studies and nobody wants to do that but
maybe even multi-site studies where we
start pooling data from multiple sites
so that we can make larger studies more
feasible but when it comes to exercise
science when I think of like what is the
field need to move forward it's not like
brilliant theorists who are gonna come
in and just kind of turn the theory on
its head it's really more who can
actually apply the theories that we have
already and the knowledge we have now
who can formulate really good research
questions that are supported by very
tight research designs and then just
actually put in the work of doing the
the large sample trials that are likely
to be more robust with good study design
and I think another thing we need is
better statistical training because my
my perception of exercise science
literature now is that the statistical
toolkit is very limited because we do a
lot of small studies that all kind of
have the same general design so it's
like you can learn all the stat theory
you want but you're not going to be able
to do anything interesting or
sophisticated because usually to do
anything sophisticated with statistics
you need a pretty large sample to
support it mm-hmm
at like big very big yeah so so when I
think of what the field needs to really
take big leaps forward it's it's a
commitment to really devoting to bigger
studies that are done with a really
strict methodology and kind of a
parallel advancement and how
we analyzed the data and present it what
do you think I agree so so I think I
agree with you that the problem probably
isn't like the brainpower in the field
and I think that I think that a lot of
people put way too much emphasis on like
the value of really really high IQs who
was it like Richard Fineman who really
influential physicists I believe who his
IQ was like 120 and he was like super
proud of that and would like tell
everyone just as like a a [ __ ] you to
everyone who thought that you had to
have like an IQ of 140 150 to
meaningfully contribute to physics and I
think the research tends to bear that
out that for like some like incredibly
challenging theoretical questions it may
require like a very very high IQ to be
able to make progress on it but like I
can't really think of any questions like
that yeah it's like really like I just
need data yelling at elbow grease yeah
like I think I think we have as much
brain power as we really need like you
said the the things that would probably
help the most in terms of like being
able to do the studies we would need to
do to like really make like very serious
progress we need money and so like the
part of this question that asks if he
had the resources of the average tenured
professor like you'd probably make about
as much progress as the average tenured
professor cuz there's just not that many
yeah like we we just need more resources
what you mentioned about multi-site
studies I think that could be really
really big I think that one thing where
additional funding would help with the
that is often overlooked is being able
to recruit different folks than who we
can typically recruit so most training
studies are done on either college
students or like early career
faculty who work at the university but
like mostly college students reason for
that is if you're gonna ask someone to
like follow your your research training
protocol for like 10 12 weeks whatever
like you typically have to pay them and
so you're limited in terms of how long
studies can run because you know it's
it's a relatively big ask to say you
know come to the lab three times a week
for 12 weeks and we're gonna do this
training program it's a much bigger ask
to say yeah and you can't go home for
Thanksgiving break you can't go home for
spring break
you can't go home for winter break we're
gonna need you to stay here over the
summer like I there's there's a reason
why a lot of the training studies that
get published in the spring or like 10
to 12 weeks and then the ones that get
published in like the summer and fall
are like six weeks and it's because of
spring break like you can run a longer
training study in the fall because a lot
of times people aren't going home until
Thanksgiving break and you can run
shorter ones in the spring because like
spring break takes place smack dab in
the middle of the semester so you know
you can take half your cohort through
six weeks like before spring break and
like the other half through six weeks
after spring break so with more money
you could then go out to like local gyms
in the community and ask like adults who
value their time more than the average
college student does like hey will you
come do my training program for like six
months or something like that
and whereas you may have to pay a
college student like seventy five bucks
to say like yep this is worth it that's
a lot of chick-fil-a you might have to
pay someone with like a job and a family
who values their time or considerably
more money to get them to agree to it so
yeah like people ask all the time like
me and we really need these long-term
training studies when are we gonna get
them and it's like when people get more
[ __ ] funding man like yeah that's
that's the problem and and then like you
also need money to pay a bunch of
additional research staff because like
if you have a PhD and you're a tenured
professor you'll probably see it below
your pay grade to take 50 people through
the same training probe
three times a week and like invest like
[ __ ] 600 hours of your life into just
doing that so like then you need people
in your lab you need funding for them to
be able to do their own projects or you
need to be able to like pay research
assistants who aren't like masters or
PhD students to help out with that stuff
so like it really just comes down to
money like I think that's that that's
the main hurdle we have as the field not
insufficient IQ yeah it's the money it's
like you said it's the schedule cuz like
because of the money now it's like we're
basically gonna recruit college students
like that's how it's gonna be and then
you're like okay well there's huge
schedule hurdles when it comes to
holidays and breaks in the fall in the
spring obviously in the winter and then
the summer comes along and you're like
great we have like this huge interrupted
block of time go to a college campus in
July like good luck finding a human
being there it's like a ghost town at
most colleges so I mean the logistical
hurdles are huge another thing I think
that's a problem is when you look at the
timeline of a study it's like if it's a
student-run study it's like well I had
to graduate like I'm not gonna do it
18-month training intervention because
my whole degree is basically 18 months
and then when it comes to like young
faculty members that are really
enthusiastic about cranking out studies
it's like you could do a one-year
training intervention and get one paper
or you could do like for short studies
in that mean time and the people that
are gonna decide to either fire or
promote you are gonna view that as four
times better yeah so I think along with
emphasizing the resources it's almost
it's also a matter of taking a close
look at what the incentives are yeah for
sure
so are you incentivized to do one really
fantastic study or for suitable studies
and I think right now the structure if
your pre tenure it is more rewarding to
do for suitable studies
than one incredible one yeah and so I
think those are the the big things that
kind of hold things back now a similar
question this is a long question I'm not
gonna read the whole thing but it's
Willie and to his credit he apologized
for a long question we forgive you
Willie
so last five five years or so there's
been a replication crisis of sorts in
the social sciences and some biomedical
sciences and the question is basically
[Music]
what findings of exercise physiology are
you most confident will replicate and
how do you think these factors in other
fields will kind of carry over to
exercise science when it comes to the
movement for more open science
reproducibility concerns and things of
that nature now I know this is important
to you this is like a big thing of yours
yeah yeah so first things first I think
that I think that we first need to ask
the question of what does replication
and reproducibility mean when I see this
discuss like on social media from either
like researchers or like people that
just follow Exercise Science Research in
general they're like so oftentimes like
there could be a body of research that
is generally coming to a similar
conclusion but then like a new paper is
published it's asking a similar question
and it comes to like us or it has like
slightly different findings and it's
like oh man why didn't they replicate
what the findings of the field were
previously and it's like it's not
necessarily a problem because if they
used a different population they had a
slightly different experimental setup
you shouldn't necessarily expect like
the exact same results or if say there's
a paper that had statistically
significant findings but it's like a
p-value of like 0.03 and then another
study comes out and it has null findings
but it's like kind of P is 0.2 or
something lean
in the same general direction those
aren't conflicting findings like they're
the same general findings it's just
maybe the magnitude was slightly larger
in one study or power was a little
greater because the sample sizes were
bigger so so like one I think I think
you need to understand what like
replication reproducibility actually
means so one of the reasons why it was
kind of shocking in psychology is they
have pretty big studies like definitely
compared to exercise science like
they'll have two 300 people in a study
whereas we'll have 30 if we're lucky it
makes me furious my girlfriend does
psychology research and a lot of it is
survey based mm-hmm they'll put a survey
up on Monday and by Thursday they have
400 responses yeah in the column a day
it makes me so upset but yeah so one of
the reasons like in psychology you're
like in biomedicine which like those
studies are more like time intensive but
they also have more funding so they can
get more people through one of the
reasons it was so shocking in fields
like that is they do have big studies
that that should have the power to
reliably come to two proper conclusions
and then the the replication projects
they did is they would like repeat the
exact same protocol of the first study
that came to these findings so you know
recruiting from the same population like
same method same experimental setup and
they're getting they're getting like
very different findings so wine one I
think before we can really have like a
reproducibility project or
reproducibility crisis in exercise
science one we need big enough studies
that it would actually be shocking if
they didn't replicate and not just like
well we just found different results due
to sampling issues and then to like we
never do direct one-to-one replications
that just like doesn't happen this so
it's hard to know what the state of like
the replication crisis
is an exercise science because we're not
currently at a point as a field where we
can know if it's a thing the other thing
I would say is so you need to think
about the factors that led to the
replication crisis being a problem in
certain fields in the first place and
one of the big issues was with
publication bias so you do a study and
the results come in and it's like not
really the results I'm interested in
let's just do it again and like you said
with psychology you'd like if you want
to do the same study like three or four
times it's like oh well now data
collection has been extended from three
days to like two and a half weeks yeah
and it will cost you like in some cases
a few hundred dollars yeah yeah so so so
publication bias could exist on the end
of the researchers where it's like well
what do I actually submit to try to get
published or it could be on the side of
the journals of like well am I only
going to accept like statistically
significant positive findings or are we
going to accept nulls as well and I
think that honestly for all of for all
of the shade I'll throw at exercise
science as a field I kind of think that
at least publication bias probably isn't
quite as bad in exercise science as it
may be in other fields because funding
is so limited in the amount of studies
we can do is so limited that for the
most part and studies are just so time
and labor intensive that for the most
part if we do something we are really
really going to try to get it published
because you know you put a ton of time
and effort into that you need to get
studies published to either like get
into a ph.d program or get hired or like
get promoted and so like you're gonna
try to get pretty much everything you do
published and so I think like the aspect
of publication bias on the side of
researchers is probably a little bit
less in exercise science and it would be
in other fields and then I think that
the the issue
with journals is probably a little bit
lower than it would be in other fields
as well so there's there's something
called P curves Yuri Simonson I believe
was was the main guy who came up with
this and essentially what you can do is
you look at the published research in a
field you look at the the distribution
of P values for the significantly earth
for the statistically significant
findings that are published and based on
the distribution of P values you see you
can get a pretty decent idea of what the
power of these significant findings are
and like how many of them are probably
being like P hacked with either just
like selective reporting or like like
statistical [ __ ] like how many
significant findings are being published
that maybe shouldn't be and so I checked
out a journal of strength and
conditioning research and medicine and
science and sport and exercise which are
like two of the bigger journals in our
field and there P curves actually looked
pretty good and they were actually
publishing quite a few null findings so
so I'm sure that there's publication
bias on the side of publishers as well
in exercise science but at least
comparing like the P curves I'm seeing
in to again two of the bigger journals
in our field versus some of the stuff
that Simonson and colleagues found in
psychology our RP curves look a lot
better than theirs so you know we may
not have that big of a problem in
exercise science in the first place like
the problem may just be more like our
studies are small and or maybe less
reliable just due to like sampling bias
and [ __ ] like that but there's not
necessarily the actual like human
element of [ __ ] leading to public
early d2 replication issues in our field
yeah I mean you mentioned the idea of
sampling error so if you're listening
like if you've ever looked at in a
meta-analysis
a funnel plot it's a really good
explanation but when we run a much
bigger study we expect that we're
getting a more precise estimate of the
true effect of whatever we're studying
and then as studies get smaller and
smaller we would expect that their their
effect estimates are going to get less
precise so there's a lot more
variability where you could you could do
everything right but simply because you
had a smaller sample size you might over
or underestimate the effect purely based
on sampling error and ideally you would
overestimate it the same to the same
frequency as you would underestimate it
so that's the point of a funnel plot is
figuring out are they are they only
publishing the studies that have
fortunately overestimated this effect
you know what I mean but I think you're
right like aside from the fact that
these studies are small so just kind of
building on that so I'm glad you
mentioned funnel plots cuz I I wasn't
quite sure if I should bring that up or
if that would like make people's eyes
glaze over but now if that does happen
it's on you now but talked about P
curves I feel like it's like the Gateway
come yeah that's true P curves are a
little more obscure but yeah so like
I've looked at basically every
meta-analysis in our field there's a big
article on stronger by science if you
want to check it out just to see what
types of things there are meta analyses
on so you can go to stronger by science
comm / master - list I think I'm like a
couple months behind on that but it is
more or less up to date on like every
meta-analysis in our field pretty much
and a lot of them don't do funnel plots
which they probably should but the ones
that do like almost every meta-analysis
in exercise science I've seen that
includes a funnel plot the funnel plot
looks pretty good like there's a pretty
even distribution of studies about the
mean effect so yeah that makes me think
that what I mean it could just be that
the meta analyses that don't include
funnel plots are are the
absolutely messed up a check did they go
oh yeah but but for the most part the
ones that do include the funnel plots
like the funnel plots look pretty good
and if there is asymmetry in them like
it's not bad it's like okay maybe
there's one or two really high the
values here so there is one looking at
the effects of volume on strength gains
I really wish I could remember the
author's name I met him at southeast ACS
and a couple years ago a really good guy
but I remember that there was some
asymmetry in that funnel plot but when I
actually looked at it the issue seems to
be more with the inclusion criteria for
the meta analysis than with publication
bias itself so like it was oh no no no
it was comparing periodized and unpaired
eyes training on strength gains that's
what it was and in one of one of the
studies included it compared like a much
higher volume and more strenuous
periodized program versus like basically
a a [ __ ] non periodized program and
so like the periodized group got like
way way better gains and that was like
by far the largest effect in that
meta-analysis and it introduced some
asymmetry into the funnel plot but like
you look at something like that like
that specific case that's not
publication bias that's just one study
included in the meta-analysis like you
didn't do as good of a job acquainting
other variables as the rest of the
studies did so like of course it's going
to have a substantially larger effect
but but yeah for the most part like the
funnel plots i've seen in our field like
they look good like they don't they
don't look like the type of funnel plots
one would expect to see with a ton of
publication bias and likely replication
issues yeah I mean the only one that
comes to mind that I saw any asymmetry
was one looking at acute caffeine
responses mm-hm and it makes sense
because like it's not that anybody's
trying to like do wrong but like if you
sunk like
you could probably do a study on the
acute performance effects of caffeine
assuming that recruitment wasn't a
problem in like a few afternoons if you
really had to you know what I mean you
give a supplement you test them alright
wrap it up come back in a week we'll do
it again mm-hmm so like if there was
gonna be a study that somebody would
take the time to do it find that their
results were just simply not that
interesting and then say I don't really
feel like writing this up it's gonna be
bad so like that's the only meta I can
think of that I looked at and I was like
yeah there's some asymmetry but what you
do is you mathematically correct for it
and it didn't change the outcome in any
measurable way so yeah I really don't
think that exercise science would have a
huge issue and you know you mentioned
like I think you mentioned in some of
these studies with fields with bigger
studies that pee hacking and some
statistical trickery kind of comes into
play mm-hmm when you're dealing with
small sample sizes like good luck I mean
aside from like legitimate fraud like
what are you gonna do like yeah or if
you just want to like analyze a subgroup
where you think the results may have
been bigger it's like what what [ __ ]
subgroups are you gonna pull out of a
study with 22 participants right yeah so
when you see these fields where it's
like okay we have 400 people in the
study and it's like if you just play
mix-and-match with co-variants something
might happen you know like you got nine
in one group and eight in the other in
exercise science like aside from just
haphazardly throwing people out of the
study which is egregious and is very
very bad and hopefully nobody's doing
aside from that I mean there's not a
huge statistical toolkit that you can
really use for for evil in that scenario
so I actually think compared to the
social sciences we we probably have an
issue like like we've talked about with
the fact that the studies are just too
small to be considered truly robust on
their own and and a lot of studies are
designed poorly or the statistical
reporting is bad like man if I had a
dime for every study I read that what
they're looking at for an ANOVA what
they should be looking at
is a liked group buy time interaction
and they see a main group effect and
they're like oh this group did better
than that group and it's like nope
that's that's not what that means really
yeah I would probably have two dollars
or so if you had how much for each time
a nickel okay wow that's yeah I mean so
so like see that from time to time or
yeah I mean there's why did see I have
seen one study where they were they
thought that they should be interested
in an interaction but because of their
design actually that the main effective
group was more informative and they're
like well no interaction I guess we'll
try again it's like why would you have
an interaction yeah based on the design
then you shouldn't yeah so like you said
there's big issues with statistical
literacy in our field and so I think
like a lot of the the poor conclusions
that are that are drawn in the
literature are kinda just from people
maybe not really knowing what they're
doing versus like actually trying to
publish fraudulent research or use any
of the other tools in the toolkit that
that could lead to a replication crisis
so yeah yeah like maybe just the small
samples and the the fact that our work
takes so much effort and therefore isn't
quite as prone to publication bias but
then also means we have small studies
that you can't draw all hard conclusions
from like those those might be the
saving grace of our field yeah I mean my
impression in the field is that there's
no like glaring lack of IQ I don't think
there are a lot of bad actors out there
who are being malicious with how they're
handling data or reporting it and I
think the bad actors out there tend to
get sniffed out pretty quickly yeah not
gonna name names Billy right yeah it's
the handful of cases that I can think of
like people jumped on it pretty quick
right yeah it was not difficult to kind
of get to the bottom of that so yeah I
think really the exercise science field
in general an unbiased because I am part
of it and have
a lot of friends that are part of it but
I think it's good people who are doing
their best but it's a lack of resources
that is really kind of putting
additional barriers and hurdles in the
way and I would say to be fair a little
bit of statistical training would
probably go a long way I think that's
probably a good place to wrap things up
so think so we were shooting for an hour
and we only went over by 50% which is
fantastic for us yeah so if you've made
it this far thank you for listening
there's gonna be another main episode
out next week so yeah thanks thanks for
listening to the podcast we will we will
talk to you a week from now in the
meantime if you have any questions that
you would like to see addressed on a Q&A
episode of the podcast we will link my
original posts on Facebook and Instagram
and Twitter if you have additional
questions just just comment on those
those bits of social media and we will
add them to our list and and get to them
as soon as we can
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another health care
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it visit
stronger by science com to check out the
products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you